hey Bill this is a doTERRA mechanical
engineering graduate from India my
question to you is why are so many
people attracted to pseudoscience and
what can we as a society do to stop
pseudoscience if it has the support of
religious fundamentalists and hyper
nationalists for example the recently
concluded Indian Science Congress was
criticized heavily for featuring a lot
of pseudoscience and mythology
greetings I did share I'm saying it as
best I can at a chair saying it as best
I can
I have spent just about two weeks in
India and I got to say I was very
impressed with how much pseudoscience
there is how much spiritualism there is
yes those aren't the same thing and a
lot of people it's very common for
people from my country from the United
States to go to India to get a new way
of looking at life to get a new
spiritual perspective and as you
suggested these things pseudoscience and
the spiritual perspective seem to be
tied together but science this process
that humans have come up with where you
make an observation you come up with
hypothesis a reason you think this
observation happened this phenomenon
occurred and then you come up with a way
to test it an experiment you test it you
see what happened you compare that to
what you thought would happen and you
know nature in this extraordinary way
that enables us to have cars and trucks
and the Green Revolution and feed
everybody in clean water for a lot of
people and electricity and spaceflight
and putting things in orbit around Mars
the Mars orbiting mission the indian
israel indian space research
organizations mission is very cool this
is a great concern all I can say is not
all I can say but something I will say
about pseudoscience well in the United
States it's very common to use the
phrase critical thinking being critical
of what of claims is that it's a process
when you first for example when someone
says that he or she is spiritually
prepares himself or herself to walk
across hot coals which is a fabulous
phenomenon it's very easy for an
audience member someone unfamiliar with
the science involved to think that it
does require spiritual preparedness but
I've walked on hot coals without being
spiritually prepared at all it just
turns out that there's a few things that
happen
generally fire Walker's get their feet
wet they get the grass around the fire
very wet so your feet are wet so that
turns to steam then the big thing is
your feet your foot is just like a piece
of meat it soaks up a lot of heat before
your skin burns it's really amazing I
always tell people wrap a piece of paper
around an empty soda can and hold it
over a candle flame the paper doesn't
burn for quite a while because the heat
passes right through it into the can the
same of the skin of your foot so along
this line you have to show people that
it was not spiritual preparedness that
enabled them to walk on fire and at
first in my experience the audience will
reject that no no you have to be
spiritually prepared no no no you don't
and after they try it or review it they
may they'll start to change their minds
if you quiz people about the influence
of astrology the position of the stars
with respect to their personality
characteristics at first though quite
often they'll reject it they'll say
that's you know no the stars are very
influential but after a while they'll
think about it people who believe they
can communicate with the dead or get the
audience to believe that they can
communicate with the dead at first it
seems reasonable but after a while you
can show that it's not true so what I
would say is you got to stick with it
you just got to keep nudging people
against the pseudo scientific beliefs as
far as the Indian science conference I
mean this spiritualism at least when I
was in India was deep within your
culture deep within the Indian culture
so it's not something that's going to
change right away but I claim it is in
everyone's best interest to embrace the
process of science so that Indian
agriculture continues to feed the your
billion people you're our billion people
and continue to explore space because it
brings out the best in us brings out the
best in people when our country has its
own space program it just inherently
produces more graduates in
more advanced science which then
enriches technology for everyone and
soon everybody in India will have access
to phone calls everybody in India will
have access to higher more advanced
transportation systems what we all in
the in the developed world very much
want is for Indian nation to skip these
fossil fuel steps that we all went
through and produced all this greenhouse
gas which has given us this
extraordinary quality of life in the
West to be sure but we want by we the
world wants Indian mechanical engineers
such as yourself to get right to
renewable energy and become world
leaders in renewable energy and this to
me is very closely related to us chewing
or setting aside spiritualism and
pseudo-scientific beliefs and embracing
science to solve these actual technical
problems spiritualism is a separate
thing if people are enriched by that
it's great but to have spiritualism or
belief in psychic powers or psychic
preparedness influence agriculture for
example or influential electricity
production is inappropriate and it's
going to hold you all back and that's
why hold us all back and that's why I
think you asked the question but if
you're a mechanical engineer you are
using science to make things and solve
problems and we appreciate your work
carry on sir carry on